the US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
has slammed Russia for sending
long-range bombers to Venezuela for a
joint military operation Moscow
retaliated saying Pompeo statement was
absolutely inappropriate in a tweet the
u.s. top diplomat accused Russia and
Venezuela of squandering public funds we
can now cross live to our correspondent
maria fernanda who's in the Venezuelan
capital for Izzard Maria what exactly
has been said
Tess hi Nikki I have to say that the
spokesperson of Russia's president
seemed indeed a little bit surprised
with not very diplomatic comments of
America's top diplomat saying the u.s.
better mind its own business this is
what Dmitry Peskov had to say this is a
very undiplomatic step from the US
Secretary of State it's a serious
accusation
pointed at the Russian government and we
believe it is not an appropriate state
talking about public spending we do not
agree with this more on that this is an
inappropriate statement from a country
which could feed the whole of Africa
with half its military budget we
continue to seek dialogue with our
colleagues and hope for Washington's
readiness sooner rather than later this
response came after the US Secretary of
State Mike bumper had claimed that
sending two Russian military aircraft
across Atlantic was a waste of money
these are his words Russia's government
has sent bombers halfway around the
world to Venezuela the Russian and
Venezuelan people should see this for
what it is two corrupt governments
squandering public funds and squelching
liberty and freedom while their people
suffer this verbal exchange following to
deployment of two Russian strategic
bombers here in Venezuela earlier on
Monday as part of a broad military
cooperation between Moscow and Caracas
we witnessed the arrival of two Russian
white swans here's my report
here it is one of the two Russian
tupolev tu-160 strategic nuclear capable
bombers has just landed from the base in
Russia's north
Wow the two aircrafts have covered a
distance of more than 10,000 kilometers
and they flew over at plenty before they
landed here in Venezuela
[Music]
tu-160 is supersonic strategic bomber
blackjack on the nature classification
known in Russia has wide Swan
[Music]
it is designed to deliver nuclear and
conventional weapons and strike
strategic targets it may carry up to
twelve missiles at once such fights are
useful to us within Russia we can
conduct long-distance nonstop flights
but not one like this the aircraft
crossed the notion and passed through
different latitudes which is useful for
training and demonstrating aircraft
reliability with its helicopters fighter
jets the rocket complexes and other
weaponry being in active use by the
country's armed forces for years already
under multi-billion contracts the
country's defense minister has come to
the airfield to personally greet the
Russian pilots our armed forces have
improved their combat readiness we are
constantly working to raise our game and
ensure that we have a modern military
capable of defending the country Russia
and Venezuela have already conducted
numerous joint military drills and later
this week on Wednesday these two white
swans are expected to leak to the earth
as part of yet another Russian
Venezuelan military training rain or
snow arti
you